- Hey everyone, it's Mark Wiens,
and I am a traveler, and a food lover.
I am in Ho Chi Minh
City, Vietnam right now,
which is also known as Saigon,
and this is just an
absolutely action-packed city
with so many things to
do, so many things to see,
and so many delicious foods to eat.
I'm going to be exploring
some of the best,
and most exciting, things to do
when you are in Ho Chi Minh City, Vietnam.
So, keep watching this video,
we are going to explore
this amazing city together,
and hopefully this video
will give you some great ideas
about some things that
you can do when you visit.
(drumming)
Right now, I'm at the Bình Tây Market.
I think they have everything
here that you could want,
from clothes to food to snacks
and even like cookware,
this is a great place to buy cookware.
But anyway, lots and lots of things
available at this market
and there's a beautiful
food court as well,
where you can stop to
eat breakfast or lunch.
It's kind of a square market,
and then in the middle is a Chinese garden
where you can come to relax.
This is a great market, I'm loving it.
(Oriental music)
I'm at the Thiên Hâu Taoist Temple
in Saigon in Chinatown,
and this is, I think this
is one of the biggest,
most well known and
important Taoist temples
in this area of Saigon.
Many people come here to
buy these coils of incense
and then they hang them up.
Whoa, a little piece of ash just,
just fell down right beside me.
As you can see a bunch of smoke
coming from the incense over there.
(Oriental music)
I'm standing on the balcony now
of the Ho Chi Minh City Museum,
which I think, I think
previously it was called
the Revolutionary Museum.
But it's just 15,000 dong for entrance.
Part of the beauty of the museum is just
the building that it's housed in,
which is a neoclassical building
which I think was built in 1885.
It's a beautiful building
and within the museum
you can find all sorts of exhibitions
about the history of Ho Chi Minh City,
as well as some Vietnamese cultural,
traditional exhibitions as well.
And it's a place that you can go to learn
about the history of Ho
Chi Minh City and Vietnam.
(Oriental music)
I'm at the Bitexco Financial Tower,
which is by far the
tallest building in Saigon
making up the skyline.
There are two options when you come here,
you can either go to the
sky, the Saigon Skydeck,
which I think is on the 49th floor,
or alternatively, you can go to a cafe
which is on the 50th floor.
And you can buy a drink,
a drink or a snack there
and get the same great view.
So, I am on the 50th floor now
and I just ordered up a little
cup of coffee, a ristretto.
Oh yeah, that is strong,
but the views from up
here are pretty amazing.
We're on the 50th story, of course so
you've got a really nice view.
Unfortunately this is
not the clearest of days
I chose to come here.
It's sort of raining, but
it's still a good view of the city.
(Oriental music)
I am at the Independence Palace,
which is also known as
the Reunification Palace,
and this is right in the heart
of Saigon, Ho Chi Minh City.
One of the most important
attractions, landmarks.
But formerly it was
the main seat and house
of the President of the
Republic of Vietnam.
And now, they've turned
it more into a museum.
Although they still, I think they still
use it for government meetings and events.
I think they're having actually a meeting
right now as we were inside.
But you can really go
to many different floors
and the basement was probably the most,
one of the most interesting parts.
(Choral music)
I am at the Notre Dame Cathedral,
which is right in the
center of Ho Chi Minh City.
And this is one of the
most important landmarks
and churches, Catholic cathedrals,
built in the Neo-Romanesque style.
The most noticeable features of the church
are the 40 meter high towers, spires,
the duo of them on either side.
And this is a beautiful,
a beautiful cathedral
and just a really great environment
here in Ho Chi Minh City,
so this is a place you must
visit when you are here.
(choral music)
Right now I am at the
Central Post Office in Saigon
and it's actually right across the street
from the Cathedral of Notre Dame.
One of the reasons it's very famous
is because the architect
was Gustave Eiffel,
who also designed the Eiffel Tower,
and actually you can buy a
post card to send it from here,
but there's also some souvenirs.
It's sort of turned into
a tourist attraction,
but at the same time it's a
practical tourist attraction
and it's a really beautiful building.
The wrought iron, green
wrought iron gates,
and what I also really like about inside
is the beautifully tiled floor.
Right now I am at the War Remnants Museum,
and it's actually very close
to the Independence Palace.
This is not a fun, or
exciting place to visit,
but it is a place to come to pay respect
and to remember the brutal
history of the war in Vietnam.
Outside are many displays of tanks
and military weapons and vehicles.
And then inside it's actually mostly
exhibitions of photography
showing the horrible events
and the, just the terrible violence
that was a result of the war.
(somber music)
I'm standing outside
the Saigon Opera House,
which is one of the most recognizable
landmark buildings in
all of Ho Chi Minh City,
and it's a really beautiful building,
built in the French Colonial period.
I think it was built in 1897,
but they also still have a show here.
So you can purchase
tickets to go to the show
and then see the inside of it,
or you can just see it from the outside
and just admire the architecture
and the French Colonial building.
(French music)
Right now I am on Dong Khoi Street.
This is one of the most
famous streets in Saigon,
especially for its upscale shopping malls
and boutiques and hotels.
So if you're looking to
do some upscale shopping
and get some fresh designer wear,
you definitely need to come and explore
the Dong Khoi area in Ho Chi Minh City.
Alright I just came into the Saigon Zoo,
which is also on the same
property as the Botanic Gardens.
So far it's just a really
beautiful, tree lined,
big huge trees.
It's really lush and green and cool
and quiet and peaceful in here compared to
the loud, rowdy motor-scooter
filled roads outside.
The zoo itself, the animal displays
and cages are not fantastic.
The animals don't look too happy,
but definitely the grounds
and the Botanic Gardens are beautiful.
I think that's what's
worth coming here for
is definitely the Botanic Gardens.
Many people are like
relaxing on the grass,
having picnics and taking naps.
There are a few different
coffee shops around,
as well as places to eat ice cream,
and even a full food court.
So I think this place is
definitely worth coming
just to walk around the
really nice and lush gardens
and to just take a break
from the outside scooter, motor traffic.
Alright, I am at the
Museum of Traditional Vietnamese Medicine.
I think she said it's
the first private museum
in Saigon, or maybe even in Vietnam.
I mean it focuses on Vietnamese
traditional medicine,
holistic medicine, lots of
herbs and natural remedies.
Vietnamese medicine is very
influenced by Chinese medicine,
and yet at the same time
it pulls together medicine,
Vietnamese medicine from the
north, as well as the south,
and also throughout Vietnam.
This is just a very impressive,
peaceful and quiet museum.
And I think this is a great place to visit
when you're in Saigon.
She said that I can try on
some traditional Vietnamese
medicine man clothing.
(drumming)
I am a Vietnamese medicine man.
Whoa, this thing is heavy.
You could lift weights with this thing.
(drumming)
I am at the San Art Gallery in Saigon
and this is one of the few independent,
nonprofit art gallery,
creative spaces in the city.
If you are a lover of art
when you come to Saigon,
you should definitely check out one of,
either the San Art Gallery
or there's another couple of art galleries
as well in the city that
you should check out.
(upbeat music)
We are at Turtle Lake, which is
this roundabout right
in the heart of Saigon.
And this is a very popular place for,
especially young people to hang out.
It's so action packed,
but people are nice,
and people are just all
having a great time.
I think that's, that's one of
the great things about Vietnam
is that people, people
genuinely have a great time
and enjoy socializing
and just hanging out,
and I think just enjoying life.
(upbeat Oriental music)
(traffic moving)
Right now I am at Ben Thanh Market,
which is right in the center of Saigon
and surrounded by a giant roundabout.
This is one of the most
famous markets in the city.
Basically everything you can imagine
is available to purchase
here, souvenirs, food.
There are lots of like
dried fruit and snacks,
and as well as there are
some food stalls as well.
But this is a very central, Saigon market
that you should visit when you're in town.
(upbeat music)
I am in the Phu My Hung
area, or sort of a district.
It's an upscale area of town,
but it's also a newly
developed area of town.
It's a really nice place to walk around.
It has a totally different feel
from the chaos of central Saigon.
It's much more relaxed and
not nearly as busy with traffic.
One of the most famous things
is the Starlight Bridge,
with a waterfall that lights up
in a rainbow of different colors.
That is supposed to be one of the
most romantic places in Saigon.
So if you are looking for a great
hang out, date spot,
you might wanna check it out.
(upbeat music)
I just bought my ticket to the Vietnamese
traditional Water Puppet Show
and I'm at the Golden
Dragon Water Puppet Theater.
So now just waiting,
my ticket is for the 6:30 pm performance
and I'm excited to see this
traditional art performance.
(Oriental music)
I'm at the History Museum,
the Vietnamese History Museum.
And it's actually right,
kind of in the same property
as the Botanic Garden and the Saigon Zoo.
The museum goes through
the history of Vietnam,
starting from the Bronze
period, Bronze Age period.
There are lots of pottery,
lots of porcelain, weapons.
Also inside the museum
there's a big collection of
Angkor Wat sculptures and reliefs
and stone, stone carvings.
So I think that was probably
my favorite part of the museum.
So if you are interested
in the history of Vietnam,
as well as this whole
region of southeast Asia,
this is a good museum
for you to visit when you're in Saigon.
(upbeat music)
I'm at Shri Restaurant and Lounge
and this is a beautiful rooftop restaurant
and bar and lounge here in Saigon.
I think we're on the 23rd floor
and there is just a wonderful
view of the skyline.
But when you are in Saigon,
coming to a rooftop restaurant or bar
is a great thing to do.
It's a relief to get away from the
busy, congested streets of the city
and to just hang out and relax.
There are a couple of
different rooftop bars
and cafes that you can
visit when you're in Saigon.
And it's a great way, yeah,
just to get away from
the chaos of the city
and just to enjoy the
view and the relaxation.
(upbeat music)
I am at the Fine Arts
Museum of Ho Chi Minh City,
and actually I've been
walking around already
and, actually I'm quite
impressed with the museum.
It's very well done.
There are lots of
exhibitions showcasing art,
and especially paintings and
sculptures and lacquer work.
From the ancient all the way
to the modern, contemporary pieces.
Part of the reason I'm so impressed
is that it is housed in this
wonderful, elegant and just a
beautiful Colonial building.
So definitely, if you enjoy art,
this is a museum you're
not gonna want to miss
when you're in Saigon.
(Oriental music)
I am at the Jade Emperor Pagoda in Saigon
and this is one of the most important
Taoist temples in the city.
And you can walk around outside
where there are some trees and pigeons
and it almost has that
cave-like feel to it.
It's kind of dark, incense fills the air.
And then you can also walk inside
and walk around inside as well.
(gongs chiming)
(motorcycles buzzing)
One of my favorite things to do in Saigon
is to not only go to one of the big
famous markets like Ben Thanh, but I also,
I think one of my favorite
things about Saigon and Vietnam
are the amazing, local fresh markets
where you can just buy everything from
fish to vegetables to herbs to noodles.
Markets in Saigon are amazing.
And you should definitely check
out a local, fresh market.
Fresh Wet Market as well when you're here.
(crowd talking)
Easily my favorite thing
about being in Saigon,
Ho Chi Minh City is just the absolute
sensational amount of food available.
So you will find
Vietnamese food everywhere
from nice restaurants
to the side of the roads
to some of my favorite
restaurants which are
tucked away in quiet, peaceful alleys.
Uh, friendly alleys.
And you'll just get
whiffs of delicious soup.
You'll get bathed in
smoke from grilling meat.
Basically every, every
sense you can imagine
will be aroused by the
delicious food available here
and it's just a never ending buffet
of delicious things to try
and delicious things to eat.
So when you are in Saigon,
you just do not want to miss
all of the delicious food available.
(drumming)
That brings us to the end of this video.
Thank you very much for watching.
I hope you liked it, and
I hope it has given you
some great ideas about some of the things
you can do when you are in Saigon.
I have actually taken this entire video
and made it into a free e-book.
So here's the cover of the e-book,
and if you click on the cover right now,
you can download it for free.
It includes all of these
top 23 things to do,
plus extra photos and
visiting information,
but lots of useful tips and
also tips about visiting Saigon.
So go download your free
copy of the e-book now
and thank you again for
watching this video,
and I will see you on the next video.